زيلينسكي في واشنطن زياره يسعى من خلالها
الى تامين مساعدات اضافيه لبلاده فشل
الكونغرس في اقرارها حتى اليوم وارسال
رساله وحده قويه الى موسكو عبر مواصله
واشنطن دعمها العسكريه
لكيف لقد التقيت بالامس مع مديري صندوق
النقد الدولي والبنك الدولي وقد اعجب
بالنمو الاقتصادي في اوكرانيا وهذا امر
مهم اوكرانيا تصبح تدريجيا اقل اعتمادا
على المساعدات ونحن نتحرك في الاتجاه
الصحيح واريد ان اناقش مع الرئيس كيفيه
تعزيز هذا المسار وخاصه تعزيز دفاعنا
الجوي وقدرتنا على تدمير الخدمات
اللوجستيه
الروسيه من جانبه تعهد الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بعدم التخلي عن اوكرانيا على الرغم
من انقسام الكونجرس حول اقرار المساعده
العسكريه لكيف مؤكدا ان نظيره الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يعول على عدم تمكن واشنطن
من الوفاء بهذا
الالتزام سنواصل تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
والمعدات الحيويه لاطول مده نستطيع بما في
ذلك 200 مليون دولار وافقت عليها اليوم من
المعدات الضروريه للغايه ولكن بدون تمويل
اضافي لاننا نقترب سريعا من نهايه قدرتنا
على مساعده اوكرانيا في الاستجابه
لمتطلباتها
العاجله الرئيس زكي ايضا اعضاء في مجلس
الشيوخ والحزب الجمهوري وتحدث معهم بخصوص
المساعدات مشيرا الى انه تلقى مؤشرات
ايجابيه لكنه ينتظر النتائج مشددا على انه
يحتاج المساعدات سريعا لدعم جيشه في الحرب
مع روسيا والتي ادركت بدورها ان الدعم
الامريكي لكيف بدا يتراجع خصوصا بعد فشل
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد وتقدمها الكبير
في منطقه زابوريجيا جنوب
اوكرانيا